plus de 40% des déchets ménagers
incinérés à Blois proviennent
d'Indre-et-Loire le fonctionnement de
cette incinérateur est primordial
notamment pour la métropole tourangelle
alors que le centre d'enfouissement de
Chanceaux préloche doit fermer à la fin
de l'année or l'unité de valorisation
des déchets de Blois reçoit aussi plus
de la moitié des poubelles grises du
Loir-et-Cher et tournent déjà au maximum
de sa capacité Hélène chapelet a pu y
entrer
depuis 23 ans un peu plus de la moitié
des poubelles grises produites par les
habitants du Loir-et-Cher sont acheminés
ici dans cette usine desoise elles sont
vidées dans cette immense fosse de 4000
m3 l’équipement prend également en
charge les déchets ménagers des secteurs
de Château-Renault d'Amboise de Bléré et
une partie de ceux de la métropole
tourangelle 25000 tonnes en provenance
de l'Indre-et-Loire sur les 60000
qu'elle gère annuellement du combustible
pour alimenter deux fours qui
fonctionnent toute l'année 24 heures sur
on a deux lignes de four de 5,6 tonnes
par heure avec la combustion de ces
déchets on va
réchauffer de l'eau pour la transformer
en vapeur et produire de l'électricité
et de l'énergie thermique
concrètement cette usine produit
l'équivalent de la consommation
électrique de 10 000 foyers elles
permettent également d'alimenter deux
réseaux de chaleur de la ville de Blois
qui servent au chauffage de l'hôpital de
bâtiments administratifs ou de la salle
du Jeu de Paume après avoir subi une
combustion à 1000 degrés d'une tonne de
déchets au départ il ne reste plus que
150 kilos de résidus descendre de la
ferraille des bouts de verre on appelle
ça les mâchefers
et on va remplir des camions qui vont
partir à Warville pour enlever toute la
ferraille les métaux non ferreux et
transformer cette matière donc en
sous-couche routière et en parking
cet outil performant ne peut plus
absorber de déchets supplémentaires
alors qu'allons-nous faire des poubelles
grises de la métropole Touran car le
centre d'enfouissement de Chanceaux près
loches où elles sont majoritairement
acheminées doit fermer à la fin de
l'année la métropole ne pourra pas faire
l'économie d'une d'une usine
incinération pour traiter ces déchets ça
c'est d'une grande clarté le petit
détail c'est que il faut longtemps c'est
à dire que entre le moment où on prend
la décision et déjà il faut qu'elle soit
prise avec un terrain etc et le moment
où ça fume il faut compter 6 à 8 ans
à l'heure actuelle aucune décision n'a
officiellement été prise à ce sujet
l'absence de solutions devrait en tout
cas coûter chaque année un peu plus cher
au contribuable tout ranjo